-There is no sign
that the government shutdown
will end any time soon,
and now the president wants
a primetime address
to repeat his lies.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Our political system feels like
it's at a breaking point.
It was always fragile,
but then Donald Trump
came along and wrecked it.
He's like the guy at a party
watching a game of "Jenga,"
going [ As Trump ]
"Take that one! No, that one!"
[ Normal voice ]
And then finally, someone says,
"You know what -- if you think
it's so easy, you try it."
And then he just lights
the "Jenga" tower on fire.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Boom, now I collect
the insurance money,
build a bigger tower.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
There is no more basic test
of a political leader
than this --
Can you keep the government
running?
And Trump is now again
failing that test
for the third time
in his presidency.
In real life, you don't
get rehired after that.
He's like a stoner
working at a pizza place.
"Hey, Kevin,
how was business today?"
"Oh, yeah,
it was really slow, man."
"Did you unlock the front door?"
"Ohhhhh, maaan!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm sorry, Kevin.
You have given me no choice,
Kevin
You're going to get
the Cecil B. DeMille award."
[ Laughter ]
And the government shutdown
that is now in its third week
isn't just a political fight
over a useless border wall
that Trump repeatedly said
Mexico would pay for.
It's having real world
consequences
for millions of people
from federal workers
going without pay to anyone
who flies on an airplane.
-15 Federal Agencies
are affected by the shutdown.
420,000 federal employees
are working without pay,
and 380,000 employees
are now on unpaid leave.
-Federal Tax refunds
will be delayed.
Food stamps for 38-million
Americans will be cut.
Millions of people will lose
rental assistance payments,
and union leaders say hundreds
of TSA workers
are already off the job.
-Already hundreds of TSA
employees have missed work
at major airports
across the country.
It's fueling concerns
of possible security risks
and travel disruptions.
-Can you imagine
what a nightmare that'll be?
It's a major disruption
when one TSA agent
has to go get more plastic bins.
[ Laughter ]
Think about that -- Donald Trump
is such a bad president,
he found a way to
make air travel worse
than it already was.
By the end of his term, the only
airline will be Spirit.
The only in-flight movie
will be "Dirty Grandpa,"
and every seat will be
a middle seat.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We are a self-inflicted crisis
over a government shutdown
because the president is
incompetent and unhinged.
He's virtually incapable
of uttering
a truthful or coherent thought
about almost anything.
Just take one of the most basic
responsibilities of his job --
national security.
Here's Trump from last week
describing a meeting with
generals at the Pentagon
who tried to brief him
on dangerous spots
around the world.
-When I became president,
I had a meeting at the Pentagon
with lots of generals.
They were like from a movie.
Better looking than Tom Cruise
and stronger.
[ Light laughter ]
And I had more generals
than I've ever seen.
And we were at the bottom
of this incredible room.
I said, this is the greatest
room I've ever seen.
I saw more computer boards than
I think that they make today.
[ Laughter ]
-Why -- why does he always
sound like a co-worker
telling you about a dream
he had?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] There were --
There were generals,
and we were in this room
with computer boards, right?
And you were there,
but you weren't you. You know?
[ Laughter ]
You had your head, but my body!
[ Normal voice ]
At that same meeting,
Trump rattled off a bizarre
and incoherent explanation
of the Russian invasion
of Afghanistan in 1979.
Now the Soviet occupation
of Afghanistan was condemned
at the time and since.
Only Russia
has tried to justify it
until last week, when the
president of the United States
publicly stated for the first
time that Russia was right
to invade and occupy
Afghanistan.
-Russia used to be
the Soviet Union.
Afghanistan made it Russia,
because they went bankrupt
fighting in Afghanistan.
Russia. The reason Russia
was in Afghanistan
was because terrorists
were going into Russia.
They were right to be there.
The problem is
it was a tough fight.
And literally
they went bankrupt.
They went into being
called Russia again,
as opposed to the Soviet Union.
-Look, sometimes you get
involved in something
that goes so badly,
you have to change your name.
For example, you take a job
as Donald J. Trump,
and you leave it
as Prisoner 567891.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Although, let's be honest.
Let's be honest.
Best outcome,
Trump cooperates with Mueller,
rolls on everyone else, and goes
into witness protection.
[ As Trump ] Hi, I'm your
new neighbor, Ronald Bump.
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to say
why I moved here,
but it was Obama's fault.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Also,
I love how Trump thinks
it's an amazing insight
to say Russia used to be
the Soviet Union.
He thought it was so impressive,
he said it twice.
-Russia used to be
the Soviet Union.
They went into being called
Russia again,
as opposed to the Soviet Union.
-Wow! Really, Dr. History?
Russia used to be
the Soviet Union?
This sounds like
when the gym teacher
has to cover social studies
for a week.
All right. All right, everybody,
settle down!
We're going to watch "Red Dawn."
[ Laughter ]
And that was nothing
compared to the stream
of incoherent nonsense Trump
reeled off at a press conference
at the White House on Friday
after a meeting
with Congressional leaders
on the shutdown.
The press conference got crazier
as it went on,
including a point in which Trump
tried incoherently
to explain how migrants
cross the Southern border.
-We've already built
a lot of the wall.
We have renovated
a tremendous amount of wall.
I just told you, we did
a lot of wall in San Diego.
Steel is stronger than concrete.
So if I have a steel wall
or you could call it
a steel fence --
We're not talking about games.
And I called up.
I said, "Hi,
it's President Trump.
What's going on?"
They said, "President Trump,
we don't know who that is."
They come in through these vast,
open areas.
They get off the road,
and they drive out
into the desert,
and they come in,
they make a left turn.
Usually it's a left,
not a right.
These coyotes
and these human traffickers,
they make a right turn before
they get to the port of entry.
They go as far as the wall is,
or as far as the barricade is,
and then they make a left.
Welcome to the United States.
-The coyotes drive
across the border,
they make a right, then a left,
they go as far as the wall,
and then it's welcome
to the United States.
That idea is so insane
and incoherent,
there's a good chance he got it
from watching cartoons.
[ As Trump ] These coyotes,
they're strapping themselves
to rockets and shooting
themselves over the border,
so we have to build a wall and
we have to paint a tunnel on it.
[ Laughter ]
That's how you get 'em,
with the tunnel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You get 'em with the tunnel.
[ Normal voice ] Trump started
out the press conference
by inviting Congressional
leaders to speak,
and just to give an idea
of how fried his brain is,
watch how he thanks house
Republican minority leader
Kevin McCarthy
after his comments.
Once again,
this is Kevin McCarthy speaking.
-We will stay in the room
and get this job done.
And there was progress today.
I look forward to solving it.
-Thank you, Steve.
-I mean...
[ Laughter ]
Now, now...
in fairness to Trump,
if you forget
an old white guy's name,
you have a decent chance if you
just throw out a Steve.
[ Laughter ]
But maybe the wildest thing
Steve said on --
[ Chuckles ] Steve.
[ Laughter ]
[Bleep] this guy.
This guy. [Bleep]
Hey! Hey, you got
a glass house over there?!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it's good to be back.
But maybe the wildest thing
Trump said on Friday
was when he threatened to start
building the wall unilaterally
by declaring
a national emergency.
-Have you considered
using emergency powers
to grant yourself authorities
to build this wall
without Congressional approval?
And second --
-Yes, I have.
-You have?
And I can do it if I want.
-So you don't need Congressional
approval to build the wall?
-No, we can use them --
absolutely.
We can call a national emergency
because of the security
of our country, absolutely.
No, we can do it.
I haven't done it.
I may do it. I may do it.
But we could call
a national emergency
and build it very quickly.
-Just a side note here --
reporters,
stop asking questions like that.
[ Laughter ]
There's a good chance that Trump
never thought about using
emergency power
until that reporter
brought it up.
He is very suggestible.
A reporter could say,
"Mr. President,
have you thought about wearing
a military uniform everywhere
and executing your enemies
in the rose garden?"
And he would go,
[ As Trump ] "We're looking
into that very strongly.
Did you get that?
Write that down, I like that."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Apparently, that performance
wasn't crazy enough,
because today Trump announced
he wants to address the nation
on Tuesday night,
and even in his tweet announcing
the speech, Trump lied.
He tweeted, "I'm pleased to
inform you that I will address
the nation on the humanitarian
and national security crisis
on our Southern border Tuesday
night at 9:00 P.M. Eastern."
Okay, first of all, just because
Trump wants to address
the nation doesn't mean networks
should air it.
Otherwise they're just passing
on his lies unfiltered.
They should either
reject him outright,
or if he insists on speaking
in primetime,
make him do it as a contestant
on "The Masked Singer."
-They get off the road,
and they drive out into the
desert and they come in,
they make a left turn.
Usually it's a left,
not a right.
[ Laughter ]
-Second...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...there's no national security
crisis at the border.
Trump and his aides
keep repeating the debunked lie
that terrorists are sneaking in
from Mexico.
Yesterday,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders tried it
on Fox News and got fact-checked
by Chris Wallace.
-We know that roughly,
nearly 4,000 known
or suspected terrorists
come into our country illegally.
And we know that our most
vulnerable point of entry...
-Wait, wait, wait.
-...is at our Southern border.
-Because I know this statistic.
I didn't know
if you were going to use it,
but I studied up on this.
Do you know where
those 4,000 people come --
where they're captured?
Airports.
-Not always.
-Airports.
-But certainly a large number --
-The State Department says
there hasn't been any terrorist
that they've found coming across
the Southern border from Mexico.
-It's by air, it's by land,
and it's by sea.
It's all of the above.
-No, it's not.
It's only by air.
As soon as they fact-check her,
she turns into Paul Revere.
It's one if by land, two
if by sea, and 4,000 by air!
[ Laughter ]
Also, look at her face.
She has literally never heard
a reporter use the words,
"I studied up on this before."
[ Laughter ]
That's her "Oh, [bleep] face."
She can't -- cannot believe...
[ Cheers and applause ]
She cannot believe
she is being fact-checked
by someone on Fox News.
As soon
as that interviewed ended,
she stormed off the set
and screamed,
"Who let them have Google?!"
[ Laughter ]
Trump is totally incoherent and
incapable of telling the truth.
He shouldn't get to address the
nation just to repeat his lies.
If he calls up the networks
asking for air time,
they should pick up the phone
and say...
-President Trump?
We don't know who that is.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪